mark jones from espn here on the rich
housing show how have you been mark
jones oh
rich you know what step step will make
you lose your mind when you watch what
he does sometimes you know
you stand up in your seat you start
turning around at people during the
broadcast and realize that
everyone around you is lost in the
moment too it's uh
those are great moments man and uh and
richard bring me bait back to a great
time at espn back in the day man when uh
you know we it wasn't as big as as it
was now with the campus and everything
yes you know carol used to sell those
stale sandwiches down in the cafeteria
well it was a break room it was a break
room mark there really wasn't a
cafeteria
i remember there was like a vending
machine or two
and a refrigerator that we all put stuff
in
and and a coffee machine like and you
know there was a
and oddly enough a racquetball court
down the hall you know it was
weird yes i know um but i also remember
you know you and i didn't cross paths
too much because
i think you know you were clocking out
as i was clocking in for the overnight
most of the time yeah right that's when
we had the old uh that 2
30 a.m show oh yeah that i used to do
sometimes and it would finish up a
little after 3 a.m
and then you'd have to retake the
endings for the rear that would run
all throughout the next day right and
now it's live
oh yeah mark i remember many times
sitting there on the set
just just staring at the screen at three
in the morning watching the
angels and mariners go into the 15th
inning and just begging for someone to
throw a strike
you know can somebody score a run you
know that's
literally what i was doing who who did
you do uh most of your sports centers
with
when you did that i i did some with a
bunch with linda cone
i've had a couple with uh mike tarico
um you know i've been through the gamut
there this like
yeah for my first like eight years um
i did a bunch of summer sports centers
and i don't think there was anybody i
didn't do a sports center with bob lee
charlie steiner um you know i'm waiting
for my gold watch
and i'm coming up on 31 years 31 years
mark jones
31 years wow crazy
i know it's been 18 years since i did my
my last sports center and
and it is it is just enjoyable to watch
your you know enthusiasm and listen to
it
as well like you know watching curry do
his thing and watching everybody
do their thing and and and then
listening to you do it and
the nba today um how long did you do
that show
in the world i was on that for like
eight years from 1990
to 98.99 pretty much with
you know jack ramsey god rest his soul
the hall of famer and
you know david aldridge was part of our
crew back then
and uh you know we we had some pretty
pretty good guys uh
come through the show back in the day
back before the days of the
you know the internet and you know all
these other news sources and
you know every every week that was kind
of your source for
basketball news and moving and shaking
and happening and uh it's interesting
how the the business has evolved since
that time but that was a
that was a fun show i used to love the
crew and uh
you know we used to use interns on that
show rich
uh which many people don't know and you
know young people kind of still coming
up in the business
uh they'd be running teleprompter and it
was not unusual for
an intern to put like the wrong page in
there on their first show
they would go from page one to page
fourteen and i'd be ad-libbing from
there
your ron burgundy moment hopefully not
you know
mark jones here on the rich eisen show
and then that was you know obviously
jordan uh at his zenith and his
ascendancy
and then his retirement then his return
and then his zenith
i mean that was that was it pretty much
that period of
the 90s i mean what a time to have a
daily nba show
when there really weren't many daily
shows specifically to a sport
back in that day either mark you know no
it was it was great to be a part of that
that jordan era and um to be able to
track that
and to be around it and you know to go
to the different places to watch it
happen
um and the growth of the nba
you know even in that jordan area where
it is now and how it continues to evolve
with the new generation of stars that
that keep taking the torch and moving it
forward and
keep running that race it's been great
and uh you know see some of the young
stars now in the game you know to see
devin booker do his thing to see luka
doncic
uh do his thing to see trey young
set milwaukee on fire the other night
has has been really riveting and
compelling television it's what makes
the
sport great and now that we have access
to these guys a little bit more now as
things return to
normalcy um you know the thing that
makes the nba and especially the
playoffs it's
it's heightened is the the intimacy
between uh
what we actually see courtside and uh
the players you know there's there's no
helmets there's no shoulder pads you
you see and hear expressions and the
communication between the players on the
floor it's
it's been fantastic to watch and to
witness as
uh as we move down towards the nba
finals mark jones here
on the rich eisen show um also uh
the voice of the sacramento kings when
not calling games on espn
right here on the rich eisen show you
mentioned trey young and we started this
segment with you
with your curry call that he's deep in
his bag like the fries at the bottom
um young has got a deep bag too does he
not
i mean we're seeing that bag right now
in a big way how
viable do you think the atlanta hawks
are in these playoffs
i think they've got a great shot at
winning this series i don't think
anything they did in game one would be
considered uh by good fortune or a luck
or a fluke
um you know nate mcmillan has put a
premium since
he took over in uh march
on taking care of the basketball and
being two-way players and those two
things have really
impacted that team and they've got a
solid foundation and
the guy that's really turned it around
under nate mcmillan is trey young he's
learned to value the basketball
and learn how to manage games better
uh learning how to and keep his
teammates involved
and and still get his numbers and put up
big numbers and
you know you look at the contributions
that they've got from different players
at different times
as they've gotten healthy from the time
they took over
um to where they are now uh i wouldn't
be surprised to see them win that series
it wouldn't be considered
you know an upset in my eyes because
they're they're a solidly built team
and clint capela gives them great rim
presence at both ends as well so
they're in a good place and of course
you know these
nba um conference championships and then
then then the finals themselves the
conversation is is it such and such as
time right
and you know once upon a time we were
wondering is it is it jordan's time is
it finally his time and then finally it
was and then
we were wondering if it was somebody
else's time and then jordan
made sure it was not that person's time
and then you know hakeem had his time
because jordan wasn't there and
and then so on and so forth it was
lebron's time finally and
the question i have for you is is this
chris paul's time
what do you think you know what i i've
got a good feeling that it probably
is um although nobody told the clippers
last night
um what we saw last night was just um
really impenetrable defense on the part
of
the clippers they they willed themselves
to that because it wasn't a pretty game
at the offensive end
for either team and uh you know chris
paul
had a tough time getting going you know
coming out of protocols
and being able to get his rhythm back
and you know i
i think that we'll see a better chris
paul in the next outing in game
four uh tomorrow night i think in being
able to
one free up devin booker a little bit
more
uh chris paul's uh opportunities will
will flow a little bit better too i
think he started pressing
at one point in the third quarter when
uh the clippers went on that 21-3
want one and that was pretty much lights
out but um
he'll be a lot better and monty williams
has done a fantastic job
uh this year as is ty lue you know
pressing buttons and pulling the right
strings and
you know they're a team that's built for
the future too and chris ball's impact
you know even when he's not out there
the rest of the guys in that team booker
in particular doing chris paul like
things so uh i i think this might be his
year
i would be something else wouldn't it i
mean certainly if he gets past the
clippers too
um of all teams to get to that spot
and and and that would i mean it's
already cemented his place in
in in springfield you know but it
it would be it would do where do you put
him on the conversation of all-time
great point guards
mark well he he's got to be right up
there on the mount rushmore with
um you know uh jason kidd
um you know isaac paul's in that
neighborhood it's a
it's an elite block and i think that you
know when you look at chris paul
guys his longevity is something that
you really start looking at because the
way he's been able to manage his body
and take care of his health and
you know go to his vegan diet in the
last couple of years uh
it's it's something that's sustainable
especially with his fit
and you know he's gonna have a decision
phoenix is gonna have a decision this
year coming up
um what they do with him contractually
and
uh i i think he's got a lot of tread
left on the tire he's he's got a good
you know two three years left at a high
level you know everyone talks about
lebron and what he's doing at 36 years
old chris paul right now
is is right with him and of course he
does it a little bit more
uh uh uh in a grounded way uh literally
and figuratively but uh
there's there's a ways for him to go in
his race still
mark jones uh espn's mark jones here on
the rich eisen show and the few minutes
i have left with you sir let's go down
memory lane story time
if you don't mind um you you've called
games
cross paths with some incredible
personalities to say the least
uh give me your best bill walton story
you got one for me
mark you know what it's it's it's
interesting
my uh i i had one yesterday rich it's
wow that you would ask me that man
because
as i was walking to staples center
across the way here
uh for the game last night uh bill and i
we
we've done so many funny things both in
studio
and at games covering games and he's
just
wide man like he builds in his own
universe with his
his perspective on the world and
basketball during shows
and in between but i had a random
thought about bill
as i went to staples yesterday walking
down the tunnel i remember doing games
with him here
and saying mark i need your help all the
time because
bill if you know him has had i
think it's 18 different ankle surgeries
yeah
and his ankles are virtually fused so as
you and i would walk up stairs or down
hills our ankles bend his are fused
almost at a 90 degree angle right
so he would need my help to go down the
tunnel
to walk down the tunnel he rested his
hand on my shoulder
and i would help him walk down the
tunnel and i'd always turn around to
your good partner
he'd say yeah i'm good from here on in
and um just a
just a sweet soul of a guy and um
really really a team player and wanted
the best for for everybody that's
that was that's my bill walton memory is
just helping him
up and down the tunnel here at staples
center just the bond that we share
during games yeah i mean i here's here's
something
um words that i never thought i would
say but
they're serious he and i did a katy
perry video together
and he had his own metal chair with him
because he's got to bring his own chair
if chris was his back
it's not just his ankles right it's his
back too and
you know i gave him a lift back to his
uh hotel because it was just as the crow
flies a couple of miles away but because
of los angeles traffic it took about a
half an hour
and um i didn't know that when you take
him you have to take his chair too
uh and i put it in the back of my car
and it shattered my my
my rear windshield and he insisted on
paying for it
he insist he sends me a check along with
this note
thank you for the time and the car and
my life you know all
of that business you're right i i i i
have not cashed that check
i will never cash that check that isn't
that's a great question
i love that guy what about uh what about
hubie
you got a good huby brown story for me
you know what
um uh of the the great qb brown story
that i remember him telling me the one
that's always stuck with me
is um us sitting around in the
hotel lobby at the boston harbor hotel
yes after a game and uh him telling me
about his first time as a coach
with the milwaukee bucks and he's just
coming from duke
and it's his first year they're in
training camp
and it's training camp and they're going
to a daze and he's the young assistant
and larry costello the head coach tells
him to
go downstairs and tell oscar
right tell us hey he needs to get his
butt
up here because we're running today and
he goes down there just frightened he's
jumping out of his skin because
you know oscar's this great player mr
triple double and
he looks oscar in the eye uniquely and
says uh oscar cook says
to come on upstairs he turns around and
runs back up
and about two minutes before practice
starts
oscar walks in and eubie says jonesy i
just had this big
exhale thank god that he heard me
i love it and every every words that we
you know what we call
uh parts on the floor and you know the
painted area right i mean like he's
he's come up with the verbiage that we
all use
to describe the game right yeah yeah
yeah
he was great that way working with him
has been a dream
it's been fantastic and you learn so
much sometimes rich you know you
you have to snap yourself out of um
just listening to him and remember oh
hey mark you got to document the game
right yes i love that and uh
what about doris burke calling games
with her i think she's fantastic you
guys are
a great listen what's up what's that
been like for you mark
doris is great man she's another hall of
famer i've had the pleasure to work with
and a
fantastic team player and a great soul
that
that
loves the game and um you know over the
years being able to
to be around her to see what kind of
person she is has
has been one of the fantastic things
she's helped me a lot in
in my career and you know when when you
work with somebody that you really enjoy
um when you're not in front of the
camera
it really helps and to watch her prepare
for games and to
uh you know share information the way
that we do
um really helps our broadcast and uh man
i i've
had the pleasure to work with some
fantastic people doris is uh
so talented and loves the game and uh is
so well respected
and uh man i'm just i'm just trying to
catch all those papers man
you know i bet last one for you mark i
appreciate the time you've given me uh
near and dear to my heart stewart scott
do you have a
memory recollection um he arrived when
you were already there
um and um started on the deuce
as we were we called it back in the day
yeah um
your your recollections crossing paths
with him any stories
uh about him with him mark and i
remember stu
the first time i actually met him was
just briefly before he got to
espn in orlando and you know as
as um as another young african-american
getting into the business i just
remember his wonderful energy
and uh i i love the
you know stu and i used to talk about um
kind of our shared hip-hop vibe that
that we love being able to bring to
highlights and bring to broadcasting me
on the play by play and the
the studio show the nba today showing
him on on sportscenter
and um sitting around at night and um
exchanging uh expressions and talking
about
uh talking about culture and talking
about trying to
um go uphill frankly rich a lot of times
um getting people to understand uh
where we were coming from and uh what
the vibe was all about was
was one of our common bonds and um you
know i i
i think about him all the time when i
see how far
and this business has come and how it's
how it's uh transformed
uh as part of our overall american
culture has been
great and i think about stuart being a
vital part of that and uh just
uh how much fun he was to be around you
know we we get to be around some
fantastic
people in this business and i i think
about stu and how much he loves his
girls and his daughters and
i know he's smiling on us right now
because i think about him this time of
the year because it's the nba finals
coming around
around the bend and how much he enjoyed
this time of year and being him with
his had him with him at the nba finals
different times and
being able to hang out and have dinners
and and talk about our families just uh
just a great guy that i miss right now
and i get a little choked up thinking
about it me too mark
uh i think of him all the time this time
of year uh i think about him like what
would he think of chris paul what would
he think of what's going on with ben
simmons what would he think
uh of kobe passing what would he think
of jordan being there
to induct kobe in posthumously what
would he think about kaepernick what
would he think about
uh everything that's going on in lives
what would he thought about
uh what was what happened to uh and the
murder of george floyd and and
you know what uh the nba players were
dealing with in the bubble i literally
think of all that and i also think of
him with the calls like what you said
the fries at the bottom deep in his bag
but
literally i thought he would have loved
that line that would have been he would
have sat there
maybe he was sitting there and chuckling
at it yeah i'd be very honest as well
you know yeah i i i still i still draw a
lot of inspiration from stu and uh
in those moments i i i like to let it go
the way probably he would too
so yeah you do great i enjoy i enjoy
uh listening and and watching you and
let's do this more often
i think this is more time than we spoke
when we were actually at espn together
so let's do this again rich i'd love to
i'd love i'd love for you to have me and
thank you very much for having me on
your show
you you do a fantastic job you're one of
the wonderful voices in our business
tonight
i appreciate you all right enjoy game
four mark
you got it you got it man you take care
you bet that's mark jones
everybody right here on the rich eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that
watch more right here